what's going on man she's in Total Wine
now she's in Total Wine yeah with all my
merchandise pushing the cart yeah okay
the what you say I believe that subject
entered the total wine pushing the cart
from a merchandise I'm just confirming
what lost convention yeah it should be
total one I saw on the camera I saw it
go into the store I'm pretty sure that's
total
one did we lose eyes on her since she
went inside no I've been standing here
watching come back out she's in this s
or whatever the next I'm pretty sure
it's TJ Maxx I don't think she's a TJ
Max all right the guy on the camera said
it's the sword with the black Parts out
front so it's either TJ Maxx looks like
it's a closer
one what was she wearing she's wearing a
brown uh like skin type dress with uh a
jean jacket like a blue denim jean
jacket okay Hispanic
she meet in front of Target you know her
name uh I can look it up if but you have
it if you if we need yeah yeah she was
arrested here by ewn and charged okay so
yeah they what are we looking to do
today I would like to charger again and
I would like my merch back yeah that's
the goal obviously um I have more guys
coming so I want them to come here um
when they get here what's up buddy we'll
uh we'll figure out the best way to go
about this she hasn't left the store yet
though right do you have anyone else on
or just said it's this it's this store
right here so that would that's the
total wine I think yeah I think so the
closer one y do I have anybody else here
do you have anyone else here yeah my
security guy is watching the cameras
right now so like have them looking that
way but you can only it's tight because
of the building so you see little bit I
got so you guys are watching on camera
on the or on the floor how this go how
did it go today okay yeah and she's
known to you guys from previous L yeah
same merchandise last time baby stuff
breast pump second stuff $400 breast
pump prob for sure okay um she only she
went to self check out paid for like
three things but her total was like 20
bucks okay paid in cash so she under
ringed it essentially yes okay well yes
she just didn't ring
it she was pushing a
red y brought the whole c in there I
believe she was last seen entering the
total wine pushing a shopping a Target
shopping cart it's a tight dress jean
jacket do they want me to go down there
I can
find yeah we'll probably we'll probably
head
down so just a heads
up for now um pushing the cart with
merchandise went through self checkout
didn't ring up everything I told was
like 20 bucks she got a $400 breast pump
in the shopping cart they believe that
she walked into Total Wine they've been
watching her on the camera they do want
to pursue it okay um he said that he's
arrested her before we charged her are
they that
expensive
yeah uh I don't have the name just yet
he doesn't have it either but he has it
in their system I don't want doing like
droing does she know
she's uh I don't
yeah right cuz she's left our she's left
our eyesight now sure yeah
but he still has it come out yeah well
he's he went inside what's it called
total
one hello we need you to come outside
with
us I'm officer Scout with the eat Town
Police we just got to ask you to come
outside with us okay whatever is TJ Maxx
that you didn't purchase yet just do me
a favor just put on that shelf right
behind you please okay thank you so
much all right um let's go right over
here between the police
car what's your name Mar J I'm sorry Mar
J okay um these items you purchased at
Target do you have a receipt for
them the Huggies
right
you have a receipt for the for the
pump I'm
sorry
GT is a liia
identification how much uh the pump
okay pick it up so
this the receipt that she had it has all
the other stuff on it 31999
31999 I know I watched her ring that
yeah yeah get it out of
thece um you liia see
okay
the
license
go check her to see if we have yeah
thank
you attach
too did you drive here no no how'd you
get here um Uber
Uber
okay for I got everything no no I got
everything from him
um we'll just get a
um I'll send you the link for the video
yep uh as
usual his email right you got it I have
his
email I think we're good yeah anything
else you call me yeah um just gra yeah
just grab a good number for
quick
uh
[Music]
Sasa what are you
thinking okay how much was the total
$319.99 so she's a regular with
them
let me just want to make sure
she she did was hindering her
first
okay about the 41 or in
front yeah
he hang
tight all right ma'am
just put your phone down for me please
your phone
phone so you are under arrest okay for
shoplifting
okay yeah M we in front so we're just
going
to you still
yeah
okay anything on You
Pockets put them out
[Music]
116 Headquarters 1 female
4 uh pocket in Pocket nothing hang on
hang on hang on
stay she does
yeah
you I don't I have there I got her
thank suly we might have some additional
stuff here
okay
[Music]
T I will run um you know you want to run
to them or you want run I'll go back to
them drop the stuff off um get a price
for me I got we'll see what the price is
cuz nothing's going to change what it is
right
I you have
receipt
[Music]
no
no it's not going to change anything
got double lock
this I'll run this back I'll get a I'll
get a written statement and
everything
inside uh the coffee place is to your
right just past it there's a door to the
to the next to it
yeah
Syl is this is yours hang on hey
everybody want to take a second to thank
Morgan and Morgan for sponsoring today's
lawn crime YouTube takeover now if
you've seen our videos you know that
Morgan and Morgan is a very proud
sponsor of ours here on sidebar I always
talk about how one of the scariest
things in life is if you get injured if
you get hurt that can be such a
difficult time you may not know where to
turn you may not know how to protect
your rights well Morgan and Morgan
America's largest personal injury Law
Firm can help what they do really well
is they make the process super easy for
their clients because it can all be done
on your smartphone from submitting the
claim to talking to your whole legal
team it only takes a few minutes to see
if you have a case and your injury could
be worth millions of dollars you see
Morgan and Morgan they don't settle for
lowball offers in the past couple of
months they've gotten verdicts of $12
million in Florida $26 million in
Philadelphia and $6.8 million in New
York all of these by the way were
significantly higher than the highest
insurance offer so if you're injured you
can start by easily submitting a claim
at forthepeople.com
youout takeover or by dialing pound law
that's pound 529 on your
phone these are part of
that all right that's it we're good
okay
another all right let's
uh
uh you're closest right throw in yours
we'll go 10
ring step
[Applause]
through
got all our
stuff I'll Follow You
103 Social Security Social Security no
you have an
i
hi hi uh no
social
[Music]
right do you
work do you
work yeah yeah
don't at
home what do you what do you do um
like what kind of work do you
do house too see what do you
do
clean homes uhhuh clean
mhm
yes this what we
need
[Music]
Witness
print
this
[Music]
Last Quest Jo is the the whole last
thing uh I'm doing it as
split that's how it is here on her
thing that's what I'm doing
it I know it's a little different on CCH
but we so cuz I mean technically she has
two last that's the way they do
it what do you think once you put the
SBI in it'll all link up anyway to the
same
thing
[Music]
for
um two
letter should be on there just hit n and
then scroll through the ends
uhy uh jacket
yep
and
the earing and
necklace yep is she a citizen
um probably know are you citizen do you
have uh citizenship
here no I don't think so they them
yeah
uh your
hair you good ears
Perfect Look
up you can just your head perect uh
little bit
more yep perfect stay
still
[Music]
okay you want to put the
jacket
[Music]
for
you know the
statue so it's going to be
20-11
one
yep
take out the
uh's the number
[Music]
this
guess
for
sh